[Music]
we also have news tonight on Ben Affleck
and his 22 year old playmates a gal pal
now this relationship seemed to come out
of nowhere it didn't it came out of
nowhere I don't know if we can call it a
relationship job okay not really fill in
the fling zone Nance but a lot of people
are wondering has this been good for Ben
so here's why some people are starting
to be concerned this is the photo making
news today Ben getting a delivery in a
Pacifica beer branded box inside what
appears to be four bottles and a box of
Johnnie Walker Blue Label scotch whiskey
ben has been consistently working on his
sobriety for the past year and a half in
fact the day after the delivery his
sober coach was spotted visiting the
house but after being seen out with 22
year old Playboy model Shawna Sexton and
his recent split with Lindsey shook us
the headlines are relentless been
dancing with temptation Affleck returns
to womanizing ways and Jennifer Garner
is not pleased Ben is dating a Playboy
model but she's also not surprised but
we could put an end to all of that
speculation today a source tells et
quote Ben's priorities remain his family
and his sobriety
he continues to attend meetings and
meditation classes for his well being
you have to work at your sobriety every
day and he does that as for Shauna
we're told quote Ben is having fun right
now in keeping their relationship very
light he wants nothing more than to
enjoy his freedom the Playmate however
has not been free from the paparazzi she
gave them a shout-out in person and on
Instagram I'm gonna give you guys a
shout out cuz it's only appropriate
you've been following me for two days I
guess you'd say you're getting serious
and then yesterday this happened cops
were called to Ben's Pacific Palisades
home after his two dogs accidentally got
out a helpful neighbor and the paparazzi
helped wrangle the dogs safely home
listen Nichelle celebrities are always
complaining about the paparazzi but what
would you have done if they weren't
around I like it maybe they built up a
little goodwill
he'll stop in
[Music]